Mike - Mike qui est Mike un est entré c'est
un piège
ils ont mis des mines d'un côté la question est de
quel côté mr.  vache s'asseoir à gauche ou
à droite
oui Tina vache excusez moi monsieur d'
après mon nez le mur n'est pas
fonctionnel il y a un corps qui pourrit à l'
intérieur vous ne pouvez pas toucher les cadavres
vous ne savez pas où vous trouverez nous
allons avoir  notre ami hors du monde
vous n'êtes pas autorisé aux Nations Unies Je
ne reçois pas d'ordres d'eux
nous avons quelqu'un qui attend quelque part
femme amis prostituée ne vous souciez pas vous avez
passé tellement de temps ici vous
oubliez ce qu'est la vraie vie
oublie ce qui s'est passé ce qui va
se passer
tu as n'importe quelle corde corde
c'est parfait
ça dit d'aller à droite à gauche oh je suis malade
une vache